[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
the windows we have to be present
Christophe
[Applause]
[Applause]
tell your friends
a lot of people agree
so with that they don't get your real
microphone a big round of applause for I
[Applause]
can talk loudly yeah I'm I have a loud
voice okay okay let's see this is just
one more thing to manage so something's
gonna give
at somewhere but anyway thank you so
much steward for the very kind
introduction and and for inviting me and
this is such a great crowd I'm really
excited for this so I have to start with
you know I'm a statistician with some
surveying so breaking things
okay we'll try so the categories I'm
gonna lizard not exclude to convert one
who here considers himself to be a
statistician here considered himself to
be a computer scientist more broadly
data scientist what else
quantitative social scientists
quantitative other kind of scientist
something I haven't named okay
that's helpful all right interesting
okay so I should I should say that this
is joint work with lots and lots of
people I think we're done I think we're
just done with the mics yeah yeah joint
with lots of people as most everyone's
work great so I will call out Nicole
Carnegie Dan Schiavoni masa Harada Mark
Scott where he shall lead you sung soo
but mostly I want to call out Vince Tory
who's hiding right there but he's gonna
stand up and wave quickly without whom I
think none of the most lot of this would
not have happened we don't have the
counterfactual world but that is my
supposition and I don't want to run that
experiment so and I should thank IES for
being a generous funder okay so Andrew
and I used to debate but I think I've
maybe won him over that most interesting
questions in the world are causal
questions
there's just most research questions are
other questions even if people are
pretending that they are not what people
really want to answer the causal
questions right you think about the
questions you that run through your mind
all day
they're causal questions take note
tomorrow as you run through your day and
the things you think about like we're
always asking why questions from the
time we're two years old right through
the rest of our lives we want to know
why so what drive via I just pulled
these from New York Times headlines what
drives success can we alter genes is
a-b-c-d contagious some are a ridiculous
some are less ridiculous some are
relevant to our lives some are less but
someone thinks at least some of these
aren't important right so it's important
because we care about these questions we
care about answering these questions
it's important for
as let's say broadly speaking data
scientists because if we get the wrong
answer the consequences could be bad
right
and unfortunately there's a long history
of us getting the wrong answer why do we
get it wrong so often so I'm gonna run
quickly through in just a few examples
of kind of cautionary tales so the Salk
vaccine probably everyone's heard many
of you have heard some version of this
story polio epidemic what are we gonna
do Saul creates the first vaccine ever
but they do some observational studies
it looks like it's not working oh well I
guess we're screwed
but luckily some smart people ran a
randomized experiment the randomized
experiments showed that it was effective
people adopt soft vaccine polio gets
eradicated it's a big success story
right and then other vaccines come along
down the the pike lots of lives saved
because of that one flash-forwards do
you think we would learn our lesson like
we can't always do randomized
experiments but we'd like to you know
let's at least hold that up as the gold
standard big data hits and people just
start saying wacky things right so I
feel badly for calling this out I don't
know if this person has changed their
mind since but it was just too delicious
to not did I have to put up there right
so there's now a better way petabytes
allow us to say correlation is enough we
can stop looking for models we can
analyze the data without hypotheses
about what it might show alright just
crazy talk great we don't want to so
what's an example of why that doesn't
work so this is you know from the
business world actually in the end the
the great solution here came out of eBay
totally coincidentally I did not look
for this example because I knew I was
gonna be here
so lots and lots and lots of money spent
on internet advertising still every year
in 2011 it was 30 1.7 billion and the
common was
based on naive data science was that it
was highly effective right let's place
ads and then people will click on those
things and then they'll want to buy
those things and they thought this is
great we've all this data right because
we can look at who's clicking on the
things and then we can look and see if
they buy so if they click on it and then
they buy it it must be because they
clicked on it or a thousand other
reasons right that they could have done
that right so people are wasting all
this money I needed an advertising eBay
runs at that point it was a quasi
experiment just doing a kind of simple
comparison group design and sees that
actually 99% of the click traffic was
simply redirected through natural search
traffic in other words people were gonna
find those things the things they want
to find anyway right which is why I have
to really bite my tongue when the people
I work with are trying to tell me about
where we should place ads for our
master's program right because they know
they've seen all the clicks and I'm like
I know that but so anyway
this and so this just kind of changed
that world a bit hormone replacement
therapy this is an interesting one
because it's made of course they're all
nuanced and I'm going over all the ones
but maybe some of you remember this big
kerfuffle in the news ten years ago the
Nurses Health Study which is a
longitudinal study has been going on
ever with a big heart of nurses there
was evidence coming out of that that
hormone replacement therapy was good for
coronary heart disease yeah it's great
for menopausal women to go on hormone
replacement therapy when this health
initiative comes along does randomized
trial and oh people are dying so that
was one of those where was like ah the
observational evidence was telling us
the wrong thing interestingly that was
more nuanced because we really were
looking at different populations and
different kinds of HRT that was
administered at different points in
people's lives
McKellar 9 gives a fantastic talk on
this that Jamie rabbits have some great
papers on it and it turns out if you're
really thoughtful and think about it
causally and
use subtle models you've actually
reconcile the tip so that really there's
a lot of heterogeneity and they can
they've kind of figured out that story
which is super interesting okay but the
question is if we can't do a randomized
experiment which for many of us is the
world we're in a lot of the time what
can we do to feel a little better about
the inferences we're getting so who here
has ever taken a class and causal
inference okay who here has read a book
on causal inference okay who has been
exposed to potential outcomes framework
how about the like pearl directed
acyclic graphs framework who here has
never seen anything to do with cause
language okay thanks
so we'll do a quick review so think of a
simple example we want to know about the
fact of the enrichment program and
subsequent test scores for grade school
kids so whether or not let's pretend
that whether or not you get into the
program is based on a previous score but
it's not a simple cut off its
probabilistic right so I don't know when
that would happen right but I'm
simplifying a distant to make pretty
plots that we can all say so say that's
it so we've got a probabilistic
mechanism so here is the distribution of
pretest scores for our treated here it
is for the controls the difference
between those two groups and to the
extent that pretest score measures some
kind of native ability right now let's
further suppose that there is
heterogeneity in treatment effect so
what I'm showing here is pretest scores
versus post-test scores and I'm showing
the solid lines show the true
relationship between those things for
the blue represents what happens if you
do not get exposed to the enrichment
program the red shows what that
relationship looks like
you do get a close to program right like
my entire first five weeks of my causal
inference course can be summarized in
this one plot right so what can we learn
from this plot well for instance someone
with a pretest score of 30
their causal effect would it be expected
to be the difference between these two
lines right what would happen to you if
you got the treatment - what would
happen to you if you didn't get the
treatment okay that's a lot of what
causal inference is about great
what would happen to you here versus
what would happen to you there and this
is a graphical way of just showing that
hey actually in this case it matters a
lot you know what you started out with
so that we've got heterogeneous
treatment effects and we've got response
surfaces that are not necessarily easy
to capture with a linear model now I've
got fake data here right so if I
actually plotted this I could fit a
nonparametric model that would fit it
and we'd all be fine but the fact the
matter is the most of the time when
we're in this world we've got 30 50 100
200 covariance that's not so easy to do
right to fit those models
what else is going wrong here well we
don't have overlap between the two
groups right so since we have those
differences since the people who didn't
so though sorry the dots are the actual
observations in our fake world for the
control people don't get exposed to the
enrichment program the ones who are down
here then the treated people are all
over here so if we want to think about
well what's the fact or what would the
effect be for someone who did the
program and had a low pre-scored
pretest score to begin with well I would
have to imagine what would have happened
to them
had they gotten the treatment but I
don't have any data that tells me
anything about that right yet people fit
models all the time that don't look at
whether or not we have overlap right and
same thing over here if I want to think
about what would have happened to these
people if they hadn't gotten the
treatment well I've got precious little
data down here
what to do okay so this is the like the
entire literature for the past 30 years
on propensity score matching and all
that stuff that that's that's all that
it's about that's what it's solving is
that problem that this is hard to model
and the fact of the matter is in 87 that
was hard to model in 83 so our is the
first romantic score paper anymore right
we actually can do this pretty well now
and yet until recently people weren't
using tools that let us fit these models
well so that's that's me mostly what
this talk is about okay yeah and this is
we've only we've only got one confounder
here right and it gets trickier once we
get many many confounders alright so
just like let's keep these ideas in our
head causal inference with observational
studies is hard for two reasons one I'm
gonna formalize this in a second we have
to assume we have to make this
assumption that we've measured all the
confounders we've measured all those
things that predict both whether or not
we get the treatment and whether or not
or what what our outcome looks like okay
so that assumption is called different
things in different fields and
statistics we usually call it ignore
ability all confounders measured it's a
little easier to stick in your mind
which is why I used it for this talk in
econometrics it's it's selection on
observables in epidemiology it's usually
all parameters measured or
exchangeability which is confusing
because there's change of OB means
different things in different places
anyway every field has their own their
own terminology for this know getting
bias is another one now suppose we want
to satisfy that assumption right we want
to say we've measured everything that's
important so we've got a lot to measure
measure a lot we measure a lot we
measure a lot we're controlling for 100
200 variables guess what that makes hard
the second assumption
modeling things correctly right so in
order to control for all those things we
you know statisticians typically like to
just throw them all in a model we've
conditioned on all these variables so
you can imagine throwing them all in the
linear regression right well we know not
to do that why don't we do that again
why is oh because it's correlation not
causation it's because we don't believe
the model that's all that's going on
there right so propensity score matching
versus linear regression all we're
getting bought all we're buying there is
a weakening of parametric assumptions
that's the only magic going on it's not
really that magical okay so I don't even
know why I did notation and only got
three slides with notation X is going to
be covariance these are binary treatment
variable potential outcomes not everyone
has seen so I'll just do a quick review
potential outcomes our way of
formalizing counterfactuals so that
whole idea of with our example we want
to know what would happen to you if you
did get the initial enrichment programs
that your y1 we want to know what would
happen to you if you didn't get the
enrichment program that's your y0 so for
each person we want to be able to think
about both of those things and the
fundamental problem of causal inferences
we only get to see that for one or the
other we don't get to see both for you
right so then we have to make all these
other assumption so these I measured all
my confounders all the parametric
assumptions that's all about trying to
solve that problem and then we measure
all kinds of average things we usually
don't think we can estimate an
individual level causal effect but maybe
we can get some averages maybe that
works ok so structural assumptions the
all confounders measure them that's how
it gets formalized that your potential
outcomes are independent of your
treatment conditional on everything you
see that's like saying if you spot two
people and they looked exactly the same
on everything you can measure it's just
like a coin flip whether or not they got
the treatment or not okay how they would
have ended up with their Y zeroes and
their Y ones that's the same so it's
just they maybe got the treatment maybe
didn't like a little randomized
experiment in there
that's another way of conceptualizing
this if you can think of randomized
block experiments it's like a big-ass
randomized block experiment right with
the difference being in a randomized
block experiment know what the blocks
are right an observational study you're
pretending you know right I'm saying
within the strata defined by all those
things people are just the same I've
just randomized within that okay that's
the hard one and that's the one that
there's very little attention to and
that's why we do randomized experiments
this is where most of the action is
research wise the parametric assumptions
right so since we don't usually have a
randomized experiment we do everything
in our power to try to satisfy that
first assumption how do we do that you
measure as much as we can and we just
say let's control for it all
okay what's one of the problems with
that there are a couple potential
problems but the biggest one usually is
that then we have to fit a model to that
to control for all those things we have
to fit a model unless you do something
like propensity score matching which is
meant to be a workaround to that but
guess what then you have to fit a model
to estimate the propensity score which
comes with its own baggage okay so I'll
talk about parametric assumptions first
and then I'll give a nod to the
structural assumptions all right so
here's what so we're at what time and
I'm just hitting the roadmap but you
know it's all gonna work out there may
be some quickly sifting through slides
at the end so I'm going to talk about
using Bart which I've introduced yet to
fit the response surface that is the
expectation of the outcome conditional
on my treatment and my covariance I'm
going to talk about using Bart - and
it's automatic uncertainty
quantification to understand when we
don't have common support or overlap
across our groups talk a little bit
about heterogeneity and treatment
effects and generalize ability to other
populations and then I'll introduce the
our package Bart cause which is
officially in beta testing right
now I'll give you the website because
you can help us test it then we'll go
and talk a little about how how can we
weak in some of those structural
assumptions so we don't have to make
that crazy assumption that I don't
really believe that we've measured
everything and then I'll talk a little
about why why part of all the machine
learning things why Bart does it have to
be Bart
spoiler alert No okay
so Burt what is busy and additive
regression trees it was introduced by
Chipman Gorge and McCullough about ten
years ago and it just works really well
in a lot of situations so how does it
work who knows about with regression
trees
who knows about boosted regression trees
life in this section ok so it's kind of
like a Bayesian version of regression
trees it's mad when I say that because
it reason why it's not but I'll tell you
the reason why it's not but basically
it's ok regression trees quickly if we
want to look at the relationship say in
this case between one variable another I
just have a wine an X I want to model
that I can fit a line to it in this case
the lines are not really going to
capture it all that well right because
this is a nonlinear relationship so what
else might I do well what kind of a
basic way of thinking about it is I mean
regression is just a way of
characterizing subgroup means right
students hate it when I say that but
well that's what it's doing group means
maybe they have a relationship let's
throw a line on that right what if we
don't want to specify relationship
between those subgroup memes what if
they are just are some subgroup means
well how would we choose the subgroups
well let's divide our data let's take
one pass where we divide it and in the
two groups we try to make sure that we
are maximizing that heterogeneity within
okay so we split that way then with any
of those groups we split again we split
again you know you could split to the
point where each
the point got its own mean we don't
really want to do that that's too far
when you stop it just goes on and on
forever it's hard right so reverse
turkeys were a great idea but it was
like we got a little out of control
what are we gonna do how do we stop so
these did regression trees
yeah well finds interactions online
areas are not the best for its additive
models boost and regression trees super
clever says let's do this instead let's
fit a little tiny tree to our data so
now we say we've got four terminal nodes
four subgroups each one doesn't mean
subtract off that fit now I got a bunch
of residuals to those residuals let's
fit a little tiny tree and just keep
doing that's what a back fitting
algorithm is right so we just keep doing
that so each time what's left over is
what hasn't been explained and then we
try to explain what hasn't been
explained so it's nice because it gets
that multivariate kind of nonparametric
piece with trees each individual tree
but it also allows you to get the
additive structure okay so it's an
additive trees this is different from
random forests okay random forest is
model averaging with trees this is an
additive model different right there's
lots of similarities but some
differences that's the problem you do
200 of those you're gonna over fit your
data right how do you deal with that
there's a tuning parameter so the tuning
parameter is just a little number that
you multiply the fits all along and then
it shrinks it and maybe that's good me
it's not how do you choose
cross-validation guys foundation okay
now choose my tuning remove it okay
great
and then at the end of the day I get
some great predictions how do I get my
uncertainty bootstrapping great of Jesus
Christ you know who wants to do all that
the hassle I don't want to do it so ad
hoc choose choice of tuning parameters
or cross-validation then you
bootstrapping really if you're gonna do
the bootstrap right you should be
bootstrapping the cross-validation piece
to
which is hairy yeah so children Georgie
McCullough brilliant brilliant they they
have the kind of a ed gives a great talk
of kind of how they they got there and
the mistakes they made and the times
they felt like they'd never solve it and
it's it's good they solved it so when
they do they threw it all like this has
been this is the synergy thing you
always wish for the statistics and the
machine learning coming together let's
take the best of both make the Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup right so they threw it
within a likelihood framework right and
they thought how can we be Bayesian
right we can't fit this in the usual
kind of ways this is gonna be really
hard to do so some of you may have seen
the asymptotics that have been done
recently with regard to random forests
that's great but it's really hard and
because it's really hard you can only do
it for circumstances that really may
have nothing to do with what your data
in your situation actually looks like
they ask bed time you get to those
asymptotics I'm not always Bayesian
right I'm a practical Bayesian I'm
pragmatic Bayesian not a crazy in but
this is just one of those examples where
it just means so much easier I'm all
about like I'm lazy right like what's
gonna make it easier for me this makes
it so much easier so they just came up
with super clever priors I don't have
time to go into the priors I've got
papers they've got papers it's in there
you know they write well it's all it's
all easy it pretty easy to understand
that basically the priors lean towards
small trees and that that kind of thing
that you would multiply everything by
that's just a typical shrinkage kind of
thing that we do all the time and
Bayesian statistics so that was very
natural and they Center their data so
that everything is basically based on
what your data look like to begin with
so you can almost think of it as an
empirical Bayesian kind of approach so
because of that it works really well so
they've got some nice papers where you
compare it to kind of yeah the things
that were at least standard in the field
when they were publishing ten years ago
and it works as good as the
there's when the others use
cross-validation to choose their tuning
parameters and they just use their
default primer right and if you use
cross-validation to choose the tuning
parameters here it doesn't matter so it
just has nice properties okay so hey I
stole from them again I'm lazy lots of
different ways of several different ways
if you want to apply Bart to your data
Bayes tree was the main package that's
out there there's a better alternative
so Vince wrote a package that is faster
better it's got all these great things
that completely understand cuz he wrote
it C++ with the pitch and theater
structures natively paralyzed within and
across chains parallel cross validation
it's got features that that the original
one doesn't have more efficiently and
faster so P Bart's sitting on cran right
now okay
so let's use that to fit our models it
seems like it would make sense so I've
got a paper and J CGS 2011 that
basically compares it says you know what
what would I do here let's just fit this
model and the basic idea again I'm
trying to avoid all the notation and
equations take your data set and then
make it into two data sets there's the
one data set which shows the world with
all your people but let's pretend none
of them got the treatment right so that
is this one so I just changed all the
Z's to zero does he use your treatment
indicator let's check your data set and
pretend everyone got the treatment so
after you fit you just make predictions
as if no one got the treatment and is if
everyone did all right
pretty simple people have done versions
of this with parametric models in the
past this is just a version with the
nonparametric model the nice thing about
part is that it's then sitting in this
Bayesian framework so you can get
posterior distributions for it whatever
the heck you want right so you can get
them for I can get a posterior
predictive distributor
for my y1 or my y0 or for half the room
y1 + y 0 or the other half or all men or
all the women or whoever I want
right and then I can average that up
however I won I've got a natural
quantification of my uncertainty and
here is just a so this goes back to that
the plot I did at the beginning what
would Bart do here
it does pretty well so this is the
treatment effect right so the true
treatment effect is the red line for all
the treated people okay that's just the
difference between those two lines from
this plot is displayed in this and for
each person for each red dot in this
diagram I have a posterior predictive
interval of their that person's
treatment effect right so what we want
is for those intervals to all cover the
line that represents the true treatment
effect it does pretty well until we get
out here now cheat it a little right
because there's this dot oops I'll show
you later what happens when when that
one point isn't there to help ground my
inference all right but it's doing it
straight just a lot better than the
regression fit which is that dotted line
which just is terribly so the regression
fit you know does OK in this area but
then goes up haywire over here
and the nice thing about the regression
fit is that it's really really confident
about it's wrong answer so it's like a
really dang standard there because I'm
shouting I think it would be more of a
hassle with the okay how am i doing
because it's hard for you to know giving
you don't know how many slides I have
left it's a little bit of a mystery so
I've got JC GS paper blended multi very
behavior research I'm sure you guys read
that a lot it's on your coffee table -
like that paper them alright this one I
compared to like sorry let's just say
he'll at all this one wasn't just me I
compare it to like 25 different
propensity score matching techniques
okay
but what do I do about this whole maybe
I shouldn't even be making inferences
out here how do I know when I should be
a when I shouldn't be okay well the nice
thing is hearts giving me a big red flag
it's like I love pay attention to me I
don't have a lot of information here
maybe you shouldn't be trusting me
alright it's telling you so I found a
lot about will how do I know when it's
win it when is big to big right it's
it's it's hard to figure out a cutoff
for that so I decided that the the
comparison is the other treatment group
where we have data right so I know what
the uncertainty is when I have data
about what the y1 is so that can be my
guide for what uncertainty I would like
to be seeing for my y 0 's right and
when this is much bigger than this so
when these lines are much longer than
these then I get nervous okay of course
there's lots of different ways of
operationalizing that - I like this
paper but I don't love love love the
choices I made some ad hoc choices that
seem to work well there anyone wants to
do it better
have at it so one thing I did is I just
looked at the standard deviations of all
of these posterior intervals and the on
the the top histogram is the plot of
those standard deviations for the
treated and for the Y ones rather and
then I've got a
plot of those standard deviations for
the Y zeroes so maybe I don't know maybe
I'd only want to keep observations for
whom the standard deviation of their y0
distribution is close enough right so at
some point I get out to these and this
is so much bigger than this I know trust
it anymore okay
the other one is to actually take a
direct ratio of this okay as opposed to
thinking about it distributionally for
each individual look at that and then I
used a chi-squared distribution to say
how big was too big because that's what
we do with ratios of variances right the
common statistical trope okay got those
rules here's just a stupid little
pedagogical example so one of the
reasons I like this so if if you're
afraid I don't mean to beat up on
propensity scores there's a lot that's
good about propensity scores
I think introducing propensity scores
has brought a lot of attention to causal
inference a lot of attention to the
issue of overlap not making inferences
causal inferences when you don't
actually have anyone who looks like you
and the other group that's a really
important thing lots of good stuff came
out of it there are things I don't love
which is that so much is based on the
propensity score the propensity score so
if you use the propensity score to
decide when you have overlap or not
you're privileged avaria Buhl's that
predict the treatment they may not
predict the outcome some of them in fact
may not be confounded at all so you're
not you're you're gonna end you may end
up in situations where you think you
don't have overlap and you really do in
terms of causal common support causal
overlap so here's an example like that
where x1 predicts the treatment I've got
to to co-variants
but no true confounders x1 predicts the
treatment x2 predicts the outcome so
there's no confounders actually there's
nothing but expose okay
so here's my myspace and you can tell
the oh it's hiding sorry okay ah the
controls are the squares the blue
squares the treated are the circles if
they're filled in the method would have
dropped them so on the left hand side on
this side I've got what propensity score
matching would do it would get very
nervous over a year because it would say
I don't have any confounders but who
cares because there's no I mean it
doesn't thinks there's no confounder
counterfactual because it's worried
about x1 the next one is better so
doesn't matter x1 is a treatment right
so all the treated sorry I'm not
describing this that slide well all the
treated are over here we're at the
controls of the circles treat it over
here prevents the screen
oh there's no controls over here you
should drop all those treated
observations no reason to next ones
aren't important so the BART methods do
differentially well the ratio method
drops a little too many and the standard
deviation method does a little bit a
better job but does nowhere near the
damage that the other ones do okay I'm
not going to show you the simulation
evidence because simulations are boring
sorry I always do simulations but I
decided not to it's all in the paper so
I don't need to show you trust me the
simulations trust them or not in this
case show that that Bart beats a lot of
other competitors for this task okay in
part that's also because little what we
saw here was that some of the machine if
you use machine learning to techniques
to fit prevents any scores they tend to
over fit and then you really you
aggravates the problem even more
generalizability a heterogeneous
treatment effects you can estimate how
jeana's treatment effects you can see
you're doing a different term in effect
for each individual right green and kern
have a nice extension about that that
that does this nicely and that allows
you to generalize to other populations
right so if you have different treatment
effects for different kinds of people
then you can't purl calls it transport
ability you can't transport your
treatment effect estimate from one
population to another because it might
be a different makeup of people who have
different kinds of characteristics
changing the average treatment effect
okay but if that variability is based on
observed covariance it's easy to do
right so in the Bart framework just
throw that new data set in do your
predictions and off you go
so this is a paper comparing a BART
approach to a bunch of propensity score
approaches Don Green pull with Stewart
and I into this because she was the
propensity score person I was the BART
person he so he figured it would be more
fair balanced if we had people from both
sides so part one okay then there was a
big competition that I ran with Vince
and a league alongside the 2016 causal
inference Atlanta causal inference
conference which I organized New York
and I will be talking about that at the
our conference so all I will say is that
Bart did well among other things I
didn't suggest Bart but we ran anyway
there's another there was another
competition last year there's a new one
this year you should check it out if
you're into competitions there aren't
enough of them in statistics so they're
kind of fun okay
so Vince and I've been talking forever
about pulling all this stuff into one
package so there is now a package that
answers the question why Bart cuz
I told Vince I was gonna make that joke
he's like I told my daughter's just like
don't make that job so it's Bart cause
we still are playing around is it now
the camel okay so we've played around
with what's capitalized what's not oh so
this is doesn't matter the URL okay okay
so assuming ignore those treasures get
you some Kozlov cut I'm not going to
talk about the code because but person
here people to the standard code
easy-to-use thoughtfully done lots of
options oh you can make it doubly robust
too so you can estimate propensity
scores and then throw them in and do
things like that too okay so that is how
the easy part though right I always
makes you feel a little guilty so that's
is what people talk about there's lots
of conferences it's like oh but I've got
this new matching technique or I've got
this new whatever whatever but where I
was still making this assumption that we
hate and then no one believes so you go
to a SATs conference of causality
everyone starts with smack of course
we're still making your ability boom
like but what if we don't
sonar ability again is the all
confounders measured what if we don't
believe that we don't believe that you
know we don't believe that all right
this is why the economists get mad at us
they're kind of right right so what
about the hard part remember the hard
part is this this this assumption what
can we do so
back to the 1950s and 1350s
people were still debating about whether
smoking caused cancer and RA Fisher
famous fast ition and all-around jerk
was testifying you know like no we can't
prove that they're related because we
would need a randomized experiment and
bla bla bla bla bla did he smoke I don't
know that's a good question I bet he did
he did did somebody just say yeah okay
so this guy named cornfield who is
clever said wait a second so so you're
saying that what could be happening is
that we each have something in us that
makes us either more or less likely to
smoke some kind of genetic thing maybe
and more or less likely to get lung
cancer why would that thing have to look
like right so it turns out that thing
would have to be an almost perfect
predictor of lung cancer and it would
have to be about nine times more
prevalent in smokers than non-smokers
yeah that doesn't exist like no one
believes not any no one in the
scientific community I believe that that
exists and that was really powerful
evidence right so that's what we're
gonna do right so lots of people have
done this stuff and this is not this is
not I'm not at all referencing the
millions of people who have come before
how do we're just extending our
assumptions to say well great what if
there's like just that one extra
confounder we had that thing would we
believe it right so an education is
always motivation oh but you haven't
measured motivation
right I have 200 other variables about
everything that ever happened to this
child's life but there could be a part
of motivation that is distinct from all
of those things that could be playing a
role you're right hey I go I'm
schizophrenic on this topic right now I
go both ways
okay so we've extended some work that
other people have done and it's a basic
dinner we're not even gonna talk about
the data generating process cuz I've got
four minutes left we fit a big MCMC
algorithm okay I'm okay all right okay
we fit a model and say you know here's
the what if so we've got we're letting
why depend on all our X's using Bart in
this case so the original work on this
just fit linear models right so the
regression of your outcome like all the
omitted variable bias stuff in Econ are
all those formulas that's all this you
fit linear models that's all this is
there's no magic so for that it's all
magic and smoke and mirrors and then
throw in an extra cup area right so we
said all right let's do that but instead
of the linear model let's use Bart and
here let's throw in so this is are these
are our sensitivity parameters so here
I've just got like a probit model for a
binary treatment okay simple probit
model again letting in this case I'm
letting them be linear related that's a
longer story why we did that and then
here again allowing it to depend on the
unobserved covariant but what do you
mean you don't have that covariant right
it's missing data right now to deal with
missing data right so in this case we're
being amazing so we just say let's
pretend what if we had it this would be
easy to solve right then if we had all
the parameters of the model it'd be kind
of easy to generate goodness gracious
to generate you so you ends up just
being I don't know that someone wanted
to trick me I think all right Fisher
come back from the grave
they said binomial distribution with a
complicated statement
the probabilities but it's it's it's
actually not hard math okay so we can
just fit that using what a big I'm CMC
algorithm playing that game if we knew
this that would be easy if we knew that
this would be easy iterate around I say
easy you can Vince did the programming
[Laughter]
okay when we get out at the end of the
day I'm not going to talk about that
effective medication on high blood
pressure why was this a good example
because there are lots of variants that
have nonlinear relationships with blood
pressure for instance age right so you
might not trust slapping a linear model
and if you're if you're doing this
problem okay so what do we get out of
this alright looks a little complicated
and I would say that the graphics could
be prettier but what do we get out of
this this is a contour plot okay so and
the x axes are the sensitivity
parameters right so those are just
regression coefficients the one is the
regression coefficient in the probit
model relating the unobserved covariant
and the observed covariance to the
treatment right and so this is the
coefficient on that unobserved
confounder in that and this is the one
for the model which is a continuous
model it's like a linear regression it's
upper then we throw Bart at that the the
piece around the observed covariance to
make it non linear but the coefficient
on U is just what you think of as a
standard come linear regression
coefficient okay so this number right
here says what happens if there's no
confounding this is just our naive
treatment effect estimate why because it
corresponds to sensitivity parameter set
to zero right what do the other ones do
well for instance for this line it's all
the combinations of sensitivity
parameters that would lead to a
treatment effect estimate of 0.36 and we
always that we always give the option
and we default to the option of putting
those numbers in standardized
coefficients so that they're all
standard deviation units with respect to
the outcome so they have some meaning
okay so if there's lots of confounding
it's going to move lots of positive
confounding it's going to move your
treatment effect estimate from 0.15 to
0.36 okay that's the basic game we're
playing these are the combinations of
sensitivity parameters that would lead
you to that would move your estimate to
zero these I feel a little queasy about
move things to non significance hate
p-values other people like them
therefore now how do we know what's a
lot of confounding well in standard
deviation units we actually know a fair
amount about what regression
coefficients how big they might be right
there's some one founded by the amount
of variants left over in the data anyway
which is the the bounds that are right
there on the plot anyway we've also
plotted coefficients while the observed
covariance right so how big are those
things now those could be misleading if
you've got a complete crap model with
nothing in there that's predictive okay
you probably want to trust this you have
to there's science involved here you
actually have to think about what would
the confounder look like if it's
motivation how would that be affecting
my outcome and my treatment right you
have to have some sense of that and if
you're wrong you're going to get it
wrong right you're telling a story here
but maybe it makes you a little more me
if things are not very sensitive then
maybe it makes you a little more
confident in your answers at least okay
and this is just to show that the if you
did it linearly if you just fit the
linear model which is what our original
package did pre Bart you actually get a
pretty different answer so this is an
example where it really may make sense
so I will admit though that we cherry
picked we looked at like 16 different
okay I don't they made a difference in
like three out of 16 things
we looked at so it could make a
difference it might not who knows
probably not going to hurt it might help
okay so that sits in the stats of med
paper this is in a different software
package and treat sense cram okay why
Bart and Lois done I promise
beer soon it's Bart the key why Bart
alright so I told you in example before
if you look at the bar papers it did it
does nice it they tested over like forty
two different data sets I think there's
like this at least ten years ago there
was like the 42 that everyone used and
those other ones they hated and they did
really well it's great it's not the only
game in town right there are other
things out there I would encourage you
to investigate other options I'm working
on a project right now with Andrew
Gelman where we're trying to build out
Gaussian processes to do similar things
there but there's potential there
because they could also be more powerful
but it's just a nice workhorse it just
does really well in a lot of situations
with a happy try hard it doesn't mean
it's optimal but I like the idea of just
be able to hand out something that I
think in most situations is going to do
okay and I think that's that's the world
and it gives you a again the uncertainty
intervals things like that that's easy
and it's even easier now that we have
this package so again plugging my talk
at the causal inference conference we
have an archive paper that you can look
at if you want to preview or see whether
it's going to be worth it or get your
like mean comments ready in advance
there you go
okay so conclusions I think it's useful
right like I part I've got some of my
students are around here and some of
them a bunch of the make my causal
inference class and they all hate I
don't think I'm lying when I say they
all hate the propensity score homework
it sucks cuz you know what it's hard and
it's really hard to know when you're
doing well and it
takes a lot of time and there's no clear
metrics for whether or not things are
balanced well or not and it's like a
great idea that kind of had its time
sorry
that's that's two two hand-wavy but I
think that creating tools that are easy
to use and robust that we can hand to
people and not expect him to spend hours
and hours trying to match some metric
that hasn't even been well defined about
how you're doing well enough is just one
of 10,000 ways to go insane and waste
people time and I would rather have
researchers spending time on important
things than trying to find balance and a
propensity score matching apples like
that just seems like go watch you know
Deadwood or something I don't know sorry
my favorite TV show
um do something else with your time okay
uh so Minister it's not the only game in
town and I think there's lots of other
cool research to be done in this area
encourage people to do it if you look at
the competition you see Bart did well
but a bunch of other things did well too
I was really swayed by mark and Earl and
Stroke the super learner stuff so anyway
check it out we need more development
there's more it needs to be done we're
talking about trying to move some of
this stuff over to Python because
there's not a lot of good causal stuff
in Python right now
binary dart is a bit of a problem that
we're working on group data structures
people are working on there's nothing
freely available yeah there's you mean
this is pretty basic right so there's a
lot that that could be expanded on this
packages d parts for standard Bart Bart
cause for most of stuff I talked about
treat sense for the sensitivity analysis
stuff and if you want these 7,700
datasets that we used for the 2016 data
and not a causal inference data analysis
challenge they're all sitting out there
along with the code to generate them so
the truth the true treatment effects for
all the datasets it's a great testing
if you want to compare your favorite
causal inference method versus something
else have at it
and then please fight us that's all okay
thank you this was really fun so I get
so the first question the first question
would be yeah I think so with the caveat
that you would want to make sure you
have overlap and there are tools for
that just as you would in preventing
score matching it may be less obvious
when you when you go this way
is it was the second question is that
the only thing I can do
I mean Bart has been used in all kinds
of applications and all kinds of
sciences all over the place so this is
like I stole this thing that's been used
in this and like pulled it off it hey
but if it works really well and all
those other things let's use it here too
so Jared Murray Oh more than two
treatments into treatment oh it's easy
actually so that's easy
changing the any predictor is not hard
so you just throw in your I would put in
put it in us to indicator variables
right and then you can just do any kind
so you could make when I had that slide
where I had the two data sets right
there you just have three
so you've got three potential outcomes
now what would have happened here what
would have happened here what would have
happen here and then you can do whatever
comparisons you want you can also do and
in the DDS paper I do a continuous
treatment effect - that makes it harder
because you don't want to think about
all the comparisons and that when I just
do the comparison of all the potential
outcomes on different dosages if you get
the treatment versus nothing so that's
one way
there's also Jared Murray's done some
fantastic work extending Bart to
different kinds of outcomes so
multinomial outcomes and things like
that
yeah deep learning so I think we just so
the non-linearity of this captures a
whole lot interactions it's not gonna
get much tests second or third if
they're there and really strong it will
find them but it's it's pulling against
that you could change you know they're
there you could change a prior to not
pull against that so much but it's not
gonna do the same kind of thing that
like a neural net would do so when I
first started working with Lori she'll
lead who helped us run the contest who's
a machine learning guy he fed neural
nets to the JC Jess and beginning they
were having a hard time getting them to
work well even with a lot of tweaking
and she said well they're just just it's
just gonna sit problems to simply that's
a hard problem
he since overcome that he says that
they're working right now but it took
some doing and actually Laurie has some
other work using neural nets for causal
inference that I would encourage you to
look at he doesn't he's fantastic so I
think it's possible I think in social
science which is my world
it just doesn't you know and the the the
signal relatives and noise you know I
think it's swamped so I feel like it's
almost overkill to even do this much
frankly
I have not you know what I hear that
there's a corpus of 7700 datasets I
can't have a positive
[Laughter]
yeah it definitely addresses that scene
why aren't people using Oaxaca in this
heading I don't know it me if you use it
just bait you know to predict to think
about the differences across treatment
groups of the covariance and don't think
about the outcome you'll run into the
same problem that all the propensity is
for things do and that they're gonna
privilege the wrong covariance but if
you can take into account information on
the outcome variable could be useful but
yes this is that's getting at that
basically but it's targeting sometimes
this is sufficient statistic which is
really the potential outcomes right so
it's saying well we actually care about
is imbalance and laughing these
covariance are just proxies for that so
we only care about the covariance to the
extent that they are predictive of that
so it targets it why I guess I would say
I don't think
[Applause]